[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i know one thing
wherever we go
this family
[Music]
he's our fortress
[Music]
hey lizzy with my nine o'clock
sorry about the game but we're gonna
have fun tonight
let me guess another it conference i'm
gonna be back in a couple days toms hey
mom dad has a work emergency so can you
come pick me up i love it when you call
me mom lester a rager
what's happening
please don't
[Music]
this is so tight
it's some kind of superhero lair your
dad's a superhero
what no my dad can't handle hot wings
step
step into the spotlight
i have a crazy idea
and the trap goes
please don't kill me
now that's fast
we got him
[Music]
whoever has this technology can do
anything
we gotta save my dad's attack before
they destroy the world
we got this
what are you gonna do tickle torture me
oh dude that was too long
that was way too long
whoa whoa don't you i'm the i.t guy i
was alerted to a security breach
why couldn't you tell me about your
secret identity how am i supposed to say
oh by the way some alien power source
chose me to be the guardian of the
planet
it makes you sound crazy right
yes
playtime's over kids
prepare for war
[Music]
things are warm yeah so hot you got the
winter suit
[Music]
don't not to you
no woman no cry
good friends we have and good friends
we've lost
along the way
in this great future
you can't forget your past
societies
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
[Applause]
and my entire family
is
have i not given everything
[Music]
[Applause]
and when i wake up
welcome forever
[Music]
you won't believe what i found
what is this
seeds
yeah we are so like you and i bespo
because we won't let this world crush us
but don't think that you can change the
order of things
i have skills
i taught myself
the citadel likes control
could open its doors to everyone there
wouldn't be enough resources
but they left us nothing
i need to find a key to unlock the seeds
i'll make them fertile so we never
starve again
i'm camellia
she's not our responsibility she's from
sister she's taking us there let's go
pilgrims
drifters bandits
[Music]
you have to be really careful who you
trust
the citadel will be ruthless
that can't stop me
that's far
you can change everything
i'm an idiot
it's showtime
i don't deserve these powers if i'm
being honest like what am i even
contributing
wow
there's already a superhero with a red
suit with a lightning bolt on it
aquaman is literally huge and he's so
manly and batman is so cool and i'm
just me
[Music]
i feel like a fraud it doesn't matter um
anyway the wizard gave me superpowers
and then everybody got superpowers was
everyone going
to fight crime
okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and i'm the only one trying to
keep it together
you understand i'm a pediatrician
right
now
listen to me billy the fate of the world
depends on
[Music]
this is very personal billy
look i might not have as much experience
as you because i'm not super old like
you but i've seen all of the fast and
furious movies lady it's all about
guys that was a signal
introducing the star of our show
his name is gizelle
[Music]
will not survive this
i don't know how we fight powers like
this
[Music]
you think i know how to fix this dude
but i really don't
everyone can be worthy
let's give it a chance
go fight for your family go fight for
the world
right now
i just threw a truck at a dragon i love
my life
[Music]
foreign
okay
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay that is new glad you guys are still
finding ways to spice things up we're
leaving in five okay
these are the amazing
people i'm gonna be spending the break
with group shot
i kind of wanted to save the surprise
but whatever i'll tell you guys now it's
a smart house so i'll send you guys the
link
okay let's do this
now you guys are excited told you to
come through
wow
andrew collins you go by drew right
welcome home
i've been designed and programmed to
cater to your every need so she's like
the house or what
most people just call me margo
kitty
now go explore
i have quite the weekend in store for
you
what is this this entire place is one
gigantic 3d printer
don't tell me you can't handle this
did you hear that
this is something i've been working on
for a long time
who wants to
haven't reached the party
yet
[Music]
prepare yourself for a journey beyond
what is possible walt disney animation
studios proudly presents strange world
a new motion picture event price
yourself
travel past space and time to a place of
infinite mystery unlike anything you've
ever seen
where in the world are we
[Music]
we are in way over our heads
i'm not an explorer i'm a farmer
[Music]
we need to get out of here
if you want to back out this is the time
to do it
really
no
messing with you come on let's make
history
[Music]
your wife is ready to go home her vitals
brain activity and battery have all been
charged and are ready for companionship
how do you feel
feel
familiar
[Music]
they are people too they're becoming
more and more aware they need rights no
more sex slaves
why would someone steal a companion
it's not a stomach it's an organization
we're running out of time meredith
we need you to remember
remember what
let's get a good look at the guy her
she said she ran narrative off her path
on purpose
william told me how you people steal
companions you reprogram them to do
awful things i need to speak to mary
inventor
now she mentioned a man in the mask the
one who hacked into my dreams she says
he and i go way back
how are we connected
i have a minute of your time what's your
name
i remember
this isn't love
i remember everything
[Applause]
[Music]
what if i told you
that today
you'll leave here
different
i'm talking
to you
bro what'd you see someone above the
clouds that's big i'll be big
you think whatever kill pops is out
there
[Music]
right here
you
are gonna witness
an absolute spectacle
[Music]
so what happens next
are you ready
are you ready
[Music]
here we go
i'm talking rich and famous for life
there's plenty of videos for flying [ __ ]
online ain't nobody gonna get what we
gonna get what are we gonna get the
money shot what's up undeniable proof of
aliens on camera
the oprah shot
you guys gonna tell me what's going on
hell no
there's something out here are you the
only person in the world that can get it
on film
that cloud they moved an edge it's
aliens
they're just waiting for the perfect
time to shove metal probes up our asses
i'll be rooting for you
i think we pissed them off
they repainted your house
they gonna come back
you ready
we got some work to do
nope i'll get him out
and i'll get the shot let's go baby
let's go
i need y'all to tell me what did you see
in a cloud
well it's not what you think
they took me
they took them all
i've got to get
my brother is out there
i don't think they thank you
if you don't look at
it where you end up with the top of the
mountain
it's the one you never wake up from
you'll be getting a call from my
supervisor asking how my service was
five stars angel five stars
my powers
are not a gift
but a curse
is born out of rage
[Music]
black adam
you believe you are not worthy
but you have two parts
you can be the destroyer of this world
or you can be its savior
the world needed a hero
[Applause]
instead it got me
[Music]
kids get to pop corner let me tell you
the story of the space viking thor
odinson
he was no ordinary man he was a god
after saving planet earth for the 500th
time thor set off on a new journey
well he got in shape
he went from dead bod
to godbod
and after all that
he reclaimed his title
as the one and only four
oh spook too soon
jane
[Music]
the old ex-girlfriend
what's a family three four years eight
years seven months and six days give or
take
am i um sensing feelings
[Music]
well you're right
the only ones who gods care about
is themselves
so this is my vow
all gods will die
i just want to say that was very very
impressive what you did back there
[Music]
it's just my first bad guy
[Music]
you never forget your first
[Music]
worth fighting for
[Music]
let's see who you are i take off your
disguise
and flick
oh you flick too hard damn it
should we help him eventually great
[Music]
buzz lightyear mission log stardate 3901
after a full year of being marooned our
first hyper speed test flight is a go
who were you talking uh no one you were
narrating again i was not just doing the
mission log you do know no one ever
listens to that i know that narrating
helps me focus
ready captain light you ready as i'll
ever be commander hawthorne this is
exciting a new adventure i'm gonna grant
you four minutes to be off planet but
then you come right back to us
to infinity and beyond
and you are clear for hyperlaunch
buzz that was utterly terrifying and i
regret having joined you
buzz lightyear star command come in star
command
why don't they answer
hey
the robots the what
what is happening right now
alicia oh no that's my grandmother but
sucks how long were we gone
62 years seven months and five days
what
i hope you're ready for action because
all we needed was a pilot for what to
destroy the alien ship
i have a plan and i have a team darby
can take any three things and make them
explode
i do this and they shave a little time
off my sentence okay and what about you
well i thought this was going to be like
a fun boot camp workout thing
but it is not
did i get it pretty close i need that
anyone saying the
[Music]
harpoons right here
[Music]
the probability of survival with an
inexperienced crew is 38.2 percent seems
a bit low
mission failure imminent in three
grandma always said she believed in you
do not vomit inside the vehicle
if you are satisfied with this recording
speak or select one
[Music]
to infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it no
not like that
sorry it's the thing your grandma and i
used to do yeah
blue had a baby that's impossible
hey girl
you look just like your mother
[Music]
i promise you i am going to get her back
genetic power has now been unleashed
we made a terrible mistake
the doomsday clock might be about out of
time
if our world's gonna survive what
matters is what we do now
i can use your expertise
you comment or
what baby raptor i made a promise we
would bring her home
you made a promise to a dinosaur yeah
what
[Music]
everybody hold on to somebody
that can't be right
what
the
is
that
ever seen
see not so bad
[Music]
oh
[Music]
crash at my place
[Music]
you got a minute oh what
how did you get
how have you been
it's a long story
is this the room you grew up in uh it is
but uh my my dorm room is very adult
right no of course
hey are these your drawings what no no
good
i missed you too
okay
so
what are you doing here
i mean i i thought i'd
never see you again
want to get out of here
[Music]
i'm
grounded
bummer
is spider-man grounded
um
i mean
[Music]
oh
[Music]
what's going on
[Applause]
can anybody hear me
[Music]
if anyone else is out there please
answer
[Music]
what if those are the last people on the
planet this is bigger than us
how long can we stay up here growing old
here never seeing earth what kind of a
life is that we are a group of survivors
if anyone else is
[Applause]
[Music]
there's no shame in caring for your own
life hannah
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you